okay we want to call this meeting to
order
and the first part of the agenda is
requests for a late drafting
foreign
good morning Mr chair and uh good
it's not as bad as when I was sent to
the principal for breaking the rules but
uh I'm sure you've heard that before if
you're on the rules committee
um
foreign
is an email chain
um and and a draft of the bill as it was
sent to the clerk most recently
um the email chain has to be read from
the bottom up so if you look at the
first page the the bottom email is the
first email
and that's the uh the original email
sent into the office of legislative
services but the request
for the the drafting of the bill and
that was
1241 on the November 22nd
and the second email going up would be
the response from the office saying I
was late
uh and then the third email up would be
my response saying or explaining that
I'd received a miscommunication from the
actual staff of legislative office
that the deadline didn't pertain to me
that it only pertained to uh request
that it already been filed to to get all
their sponsors lined up so that was a
miscommunication and through no fault of
my own uh therefore you know I was not
paying attention to the deadline when I
filed it 40 minutes late and so I was
requesting uh
to be allowed to you know go forward
with the legislation uh then the next
email up is an email from the actual
staffer who was on the email chain uh
and I blocked her her name Alex I didn't
want to you know implicate her but she's
apologizing for the you know for the
misunderstanding and for the uh the
confusion around her um her advice
so uh the only reason I'm sharing that
email chain is just to establish that it
was really no fault of my own for for
the late filing and uh and so here we
are today
and I'm asking you to please allow this
bill to go forward in the in the in the
public interest
uh I don't think that
a technicality should be allowed to
uh
you know hold the hold the public back
so that's it in a nutshell
and um
so I'm here you know if you have any
questions or if there's anything else I
foreign
morning represent Kaplan good morning
could you tell us exactly what the staff
person and OLS told you
yeah I mean she told me that the
November 22nd deadline only pertained to
bills that had already been filed uh and
that the deadline was to receive all the
sponsors that you wanted to have on the
bill
well just to be clear you say it pertain
to bills that are the deadline contained
the bills that already been filed yes
foreign
questions
today
thank you Mr chair and why can't the
bill just be filed next fall I assume
missed a deadline and that was my
Approach
well I mean it's uh there there's good
reasons for that I mean this is uh I
don't want to argue with the merits of
the bill uh in front of the rules
committee but
this bill pertains to uh enabling
legislation that was passed last session
for facilities that would possibly be
proposed to be built in the state in the
interim and there are no rules in place
to regulate those facilities so this the
the the bill that's drafted in front of
you here is uh to enable that those rule
making
Mr Speaker
yes
if you know
um are we not still in the period of
time when the Senators still are allowed
to file bills
yes yes we are as far as I understand is
there any reason why you couldn't
ended yesterday
any other questions representative
Kaplan
well we uh
I would move in light of the the move
deadline and the confusion that we've
heard from a number of members I would
move that we allow late drafting on this
bill and I I will also subsequently move
late drafting on the other bills that
were submitted to OLS before four
o'clock
I'll second the motion with respect to
representative kaplan's bill
yeah I I get that
the deadline was different this time
like I said I got caught by that myself
but rules of rules and I'm happy to file
my bill on the fall and I'm not
convinced of the urgency that this
foreign
I think if we were to have let people
know in advance that at this meeting we
would accommodate these requests
um that would be a different uh story uh
given that there are a number of other
members outside of this room today who
will probably be irritated if we were to
allow
such bills through today we should
probably not do that
yeah
Mr chair this motion only pertains to
this one just for the clarification yeah
we'll do each bill separately thank you
yes
um I think that this particular bill can
be distinguished because in fact
um there was misinformation that was
given to the representative as far as
the deadline
um and he relied on that information the
rep the person from OLS admitted that
she had provided misinformation and I
although there must have been some
scramble at some point because you
figured out that November 22nd at noon
was the deadline it was a somewhat
complicated bill so it did sort of set
you back on the on the path of
developing the bill which you otherwise
would have been proceeding with with
more alacrity so
um that's why I am in support of this
okay
well if I'm correct the clerk will call
the roll thank you Mr Mr chairman the
motion is to allow
representative Packard no
representative shurtleff yes
representative Smith
no
representative Sanborn no representative
Osborne no representative Sweeney no
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes
representative evil yes
okay
good morning Mr Speaker and good morning
everyone thanks for being here today
it's good to be back
um I'm here because I also had a late
filing
um I did not know about the deadline
being noon I thought it was 5 p.m I had
submitted an LSR for former
representative skip Berry in that
morning on pool safety I had submitted
some lsrs and the final LSR that I
submitted was for audio video
surveillance requirement on special
education buses
um
that got submitted at 12 14 p.m and
everything else went through OLS except
for that final bill
so it was an honest mistake and I would
have been willing to go till next
session to do it but um
yesterday after speaking with
representative kutab of Wyndham we
figured out that we have some bipartisan
support for this bill and helping her
out as well with another bill so
when I got the notification of the rules
committee I thought why not you know
this is a perfect example of working
together and going forward and it's a
I don't I did not print out the
documentation obviously it's in my email
from OLS but they immediately responded
with you'll have to go to the rules
committee so I reached out to Paul Smith
the clerk Rachel and our staff office
and realized that this was an
opportunity to learn about the process
okay thank you Mr chairman good morning
representative could you elaborate
briefly on what the safety issue is of
this bill yeah so
um I presented this bill in my first
term and it was tabled
um
audio video surveillance is required on
regular school buses however it is not a
law the requirement of audio video
surveillance on special ed
transportation and the issue came up
sometimes in the North country or around
more rural parts a student may not be
transported on an actual School Bus it
might be like a van type but when we
worked on this during my first term and
then the second term was covid so I just
thought to hold off
the state police the ACLU helped work
with us in terms of defining the
vehicles and also privacy was an initial
concern about who would be
watching the audio video surveillance
who would have access to it
most school districts
have that as part of their General
um
uh you know Safety and Security
I
am I'm not sure if you've looked at all
the lsrs but I understand uh there's
over a hundred that have to do with
education in the education committee
uh this sounds like a subject that I'm
sure you could find a bill to attach and
mend them into and uh move forward with
it
okay
second
motion has been accepted uh we're open
for discussion
thank you I I I understand the idea
about attaching this to a different
education bill but it seems to me that
it's much cleaner
provides a much better notice to the
General Public
if we allowed late drafting of the bill
so it could go through the full Bill
process
and I sincerely hope that if it gets
attached to a different education bill
it will have a separate Pub noticed
public hearing
because we have seen over the past years
some some sessions we have real Mission
creep as to what gets attached to a bill
and you know I I'm remembering back when
anything that had anything to do with
landlords and tenants got attached to
another landlord tenant Bill and it did
not give people adequate notice about
what was being done to them and their
rights
because there was never any public
hearing on it so I hope that if this
does wind up being attached to something
else there will be a separate public
hearing but I'm going to say no because
I think it ought to be allowed for late
drafting thank you
am I allowed to make a comment
related to attaching it
yeah
um
well also just wouldn't
confusion if there is fiscal note
attached as well I think that this would
probably be on the part of the bus
providers but there's a question on the
fiscal of who would be paying for this
piece of equipment
um and I have to say this is not
this is about kids
on school buses and particularly I'm
chair of the bipartisan disability
caucus and I know we have members here
that support our caucus
um
this is about the safety of our
vulnerable kids and my son who's 17 is
one of those kids
he cannot tell me when he gets off the
bus
what happened what went on and there
have been situations where it's because
of the audio video surveillance that we
had in our school district that parents
demanded that we didn't have to get
police involvement or outside
involvement we were able to just look at
the video and see what was going on with
and it's also safety about
this representative could have from
Windham shared a story where she went to
her school district
um so yeah we represented it we don't
want to
go too far off the subject
repair Sanborn
of course we're very sympathetic because
of the situation and because of the bill
for both of you but we try to be really
consistent in the rules committee about
following the was it an emergency you
know that kind of thing so I'm sorry I'm
not going to be able to support this but
hopefully you can have it amended onto
something
I'd welcome any suggestions as well
thank you
well like I said we know of at least 100
bills that are going to education
so out of those hundred I'm sure we
Mr Speaker I'd just like to
um speak in favor of letting the bill
come in for late drafting I'm very
concerned about the safety of the
children on these
vehicles and somewhat alarmed that it's
there be no further discussion Clerk of
Colorado
thank you Mr chairman that the motion is
to not allow
represent Packard yes
Representative shirtleff no
representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm
no
represent Weber no representative evil
motion to not allow is adopted five to
four
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker and members of the
rules committee
I have three documents uh getting passed
around or three kind of bundles of
documents getting passed around
um
the
um issue in question
um came to my attention
um on uh
uh December 14th as you can see on the
first there's kind of like a um
the first document there is kind of a
like a draft 20 2000 or December 14th
2020 across the side of it and um
this is uh documented it's from my town
uh budget committee
where we were um considering the next
year's uh
um Warren articles
and on page five and on to six there was
information about the the newly adopted
veterans credit
um that was part of HB 1667 last time
and it
um the explanation uh said that
essentially we had to accept the
veterans credit as expanded by 1667 and
if we did not or did not have a warrant
later found out that if we did not have
a Warren article the veterans credit
that we had already accepted for the
amount that we had already accepted
would be Nolan void
and would be revert to the standard
veteran credit of 50 dollars
and
um that was not my uh understanding of
the legislation when it was passed I
believe that it was uh
um you could keep what you already
previously had adopted or you could
accept this new
um expanded uh eligibility if you had
already adopted a veterans credit of
let's say 500 or 750 you could keep that
credit and if you wanted to the
legislature was offering you a more
expanded option
and you would um could put that on the
ballot in the the town could be able to
decide whether or not they wanted to
expand that uh definition to the in
addition to the people that they've
already
offered that uh exemption to and so
um
giving that uh
information I uh I followed up with my
Town Administrator to clarify whether
that was indeed like what was was
written as far as um were they just
misinterpreting was it a
miscommunication or something and the
second document is the
um the technical information released
from the Department of Revenue
which
um you can see on the second page I
guess so if you've already had the
status standard veterans credit it it
first says essentially you don't have to
do anything because you haven't accepted
anything it just automatically changes
but if you have accepted the optional uh
veterans tax credit or the
um all veterans tax credit in the bottom
uh bulletin bullet of each of these kind
of uh all veterans or standard veterans
it says if the optional veterans tax
credit is not re-adopted
uh the standards veterans tax credit
which is fifty dollars will be played in
place for January 1st uh April 1st 2023
tax year
with which will also include the
expanded eligibility requirements so
um it does the same thing for the all
veterans tax credits so the what what
would happen is
um that if you didn't put in a warrant
article or you didn't bring up this at
all you would automatically revert to
the 50 veterans tax credit which I don't
believe was the intention of the house
and I don't think that it would be it
would be um
a great topic of discussion if it was
um so with that information I want I
went to the Attorney General's office to
get clarification on the actual law and
say is this your interpretation of the
law and um I had a conversation with
them on Friday
um over the phone and I got this
document the third document that I
passed around
um yesterday from them
um
explaining that yes that is the current
understanding of
um the RSA
um even though so the RSA
um says
uh
uh to
you know we really don't get into the
depth of it too much that's my main the
main soap and we have is why were you
late so the main reason why I was late
is because I didn't know about this
issue and and I believe that it
um and as as the documents that I show
um I
I don't I did not know about this until
just last week so
and I believe it's time sensitive as
it comes up in April 1st of Mr Speaker
question Weber
thank you and thank you for taking my
question my question is
um we're not at the time we're not out
of time for filing the a warrant
petition are we no so the the people
could the Warren articles in my town
yeah they have to be filed as round
um or they the first public hearing for
these Warren articles will happen unlike
January 14th so it will be very time
sensitive but yes it it it's
theoretically if we you know if the
house agreed with this uh being a
concern we could you know bipartisan we
could
um potentially get it fixed before the
Warren articles are are notice to the
publicans
and the hearing is held
well I guess my question is I'm
I'm agreeing it's of concern yeah okay
absolutely
but just as the issue before us and the
last question was of concern
uh we're out of time and you actually
have a way of curing it by simply
putting it on the warrant is that is
that not true
uh thank you for the question if you've
understood the process so so yes it will
be a warrant article in my town right
I'm sure it will be a worn article in
many towns okay but if the Warren
article fails
to re-adopt right then the
um veterans tax credit we currently
offer 750 in my town and if this worn
article fails we would have essentially
said you get now everyone gets fifty
dollars instead of the current 750 kind
of a thing and I don't think that was
the intention of the legislation follow
through
but isn't that a question that's up to
oh absolutely yes I think I just think
that it wasn't agree with it but yeah
yeah I just I
um it was my understanding when the
legislation was passed that we were
um that if you had already passed let's
say the 750 you could keep giving the
750 that you had already adopted
and this legislation wouldn't
harm the like this passage of this
wouldn't harm or threaten that
but apparently it will if if you don't
um
tell me again what town you live in fake
remove things
involved with high pressure consumption
creating my hometown of coffee the third
generation
Fremont
yes
thank you Mr Speaker
um I just want to say I'm looking
forward to helping campaign for this
Warren article
um in the spring when when you're out
there so
um unfortunately I'm gonna have to vote
against this as well but
um it's very clear that there's a path
that goes directly to the voters in
thank you Mr Sharon the motion is to not
allow represent Packard
presenter shirtleff representative Smith
yes representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
um
Mr chairman just a reminder that we are
being streamed so if members could
please use the microphones when they are
speaking
good morning Mr Speaker and members of
the rules committee
uh for the record my name is Rick glad
I'm representative from Haverhill Benton
Piermont
landaf several communities up in the
Upper Valley area
I'm here today to ask for late
consideration
for a request that's come out of our
teacher shortage and recruitment
incentives study committee which is
currently been enacted this previous
session and it is still active you can
see on the sheet below here I have the
meeting dates in which we have met
already starting in August 31 and
diligently right through to November
29th beyond the deadline for November 22
and which late filing has to occur
item number two on the front page there
you can see the number of uh committees
organizations that have come and
testified before this committee that we
have including retirement system doe and
so many others I'm here today to ask for
an extended date for the purpose of
looking at the teacher shortage which we
have now confirmed that we have in this
state when this committee started
we had put out a survey through the
Department of Education through Steve
Appleby the director of uh certification
and the return in October was just a
meager 16 from superintendents
in November we had 40 percent return
just yesterday when I spoke to Steve we
now have 61 percent and it is confirmed
from our districts now that we have a
definite shortage in teachers in special
education mathematics and the Sciences
and we need to do something about the
pathways which we need to generate as
far as alternative certification for
people within the state who want to
teach because there is this drastic
shortage especially in special education
right now or see where we're seeing the
other health impaired IEP category
Skyrocket on us and a lot of this is a
result of the pandemic
so what we have here is a request to
extend the uh and you'll see in the back
side of your sheet there the one-year
certification of Eligibility that's
already an RSA 18939 Dash B to extend
this for one year immediately following
that if the school board so requests and
it has to be a consecutive year attached
to the first year
the purpose for this is that we have
folks that may come in and they in order
to be a certified staff member like this
you must have a bachelor's degree
you must have a criminal background
check and you must have experience in
the field
and what we have now is a number of
people in the state right now that are
on this one year ticket however they may
have come on in March of last year and
the tickets good through March of this
year
and what we want to do is try to ensure
that we have continuity in our
classrooms and finding these people to
replace the ones which we have who are
currently in the classrooms struggling
to get their certification
and pass the methods courses they need
more time than one year to attend the
system the university system or whatever
system they're getting this through so
um I've got on the backside what we're
intending to do this has been worked out
with the Department of Education and
there was one line also that was
injected by the National Education
association's main reason representative
is why why are you late because we did
not have the data at the November 22
deadline we receive this data just
within the last week and as a result of
that we know that we definitely have
this shortage it's not just a nationwide
shortage is the shortage in this state
we're having more calls coming in from
superintendents just within the last
week saying we need to keep these people
on board that we have the main the main
the main question was why was it late
you explained that
and the committee came out with
recommendations on on November 29 those
were interim recommendations as some of
our members are no longer with us in the
Senate and unfortunately so we went
ahead and made the interim
recommendations and this is part of the
motion motion
thank you Mr chair I'd uh moved to Grant
the late filing uh and just to speak
briefly to my motion I thank chairman
Ladd for bringing this information
before this committee and before the
house
and I think we're all aware of the
critical shortage of teachers in New
Hampshire especially in our special
needs and fact programs so I thank the
member for bringing this forward thank
you thank you Mr a second Ben Smith
seconds
I'm concerned about doing this on the
basis of the content because that's not
how we make our decisions here but
um
and part of me wants to say gee there
are 100 education bills that this can be
attached to but I I am well aware of the
fact that I said that that wasn't a
great way to go before but what I am
remembering is and what I discussed
actually with the clerk prior to this uh
meeting was that we have often had in
the past a blanket motion that covers
the statutory and study committees that
are caught in just this squeeze
and if actually if we thought there were
more statutory and study committees
there are caught in this squeeze I would
ask to amend the motion that any of them
that have reported late
that have a majority report that
requests legislation I think that's the
way we worded it the last time
that that they'd be allowed late
drafting so that we didn't have to do
them one by one although the clerk said
to me that he didn't think that there
were a lot of committees in that
position because most of them have ended
but
um you know I would I would I would be
open to a um a more
blanket
permission for late drafting for
legislation arriving out of the majority
report of a study committee or
Commission
um but I'm I'm going to vote for this
so just so I'm clear there's a statutory
study commission that had a report out
Dave that was late than what we normally
allow what did the committee just to
report late the the committee's due date
is November 2023.
so we are not completed our tasks
however we're at that point now where we
have this data that's
there's a need out there for continuity
in the schools for our students uh and
so it was the decision of the committee
to make an interim recommendations and
continue with our work and there is much
work to be done in terms of some of our
Rural and City districts in terms of
incentive grants so there's a whole lot
of work which we have ahead of us
however this particular can be handled
right now we have people in this
situation and it's felt that it's best
dealt with immediately rather than
no further discussion clerical color all
thank you Mr chair the motion is to
allow represent Packard yes
representative shirtleff yes
representative Smith no
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes
thank you
good morning Mr Speaker and members of
the committee
um I elect several people before me uh
thought that the deadline for filing was
on four o'clock and I had filed another
bill earlier that morning and I was
rounding up co-sponsors for this bill
and when I had done that I submitted
mine at 1 14 and it was in
and I had no misinformation I except for
my own misunderstanding that the
deadline was at four
and I this is a bill for an independent
redistricting committee I'm on the
election law committee it's one that we
had as a priority
so I'm here asking for your I guess
Mercy to allow us to find that file this
bill
and it's the same bill that was filed in
2019 and passed both houses but was
questions
Jim Smith
thank you why can't it be filed in the
fall since redistricting is not imminent
we'd like to get it out there and study
it and might Define some more
co-sponsors but yes it can be followed
Sweeney
is there a second
second
motion is not to accept Is there further
discussion
Wilhelm
thank you Mr Speaker uh I'm gonna uh
vote against the motion uh in hopes of
allowing this bill to be drafted uh just
consistent with the other uh that were
filed later in the afternoon with the
normal the previous deadlines have been
at four o'clock uh this one was noon and
hope that uh in the future if we do a
noon deadline that we can uh we'll make
sure that that staff are reaching out to
members and reminding them of that firm
further discussion not Clerk of Colorado
motion is to not allow
represent Packard yes Representative
shurtleff no representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn
yes representative Osborne
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm no representative
Weber
represent people no motion to not allow
passes five to four
thank you thank you
Mr chairman if I may just take a moment
um I now that we've gone through the
list of late late drafting requests I
did want to just mention uh for the
record
um we published these dates uh they were
adopted by the house on March 31st of
this year and I would just note that
going back to at least 2010 the filing
deadline sign off has been 12 o'clock so
I did want to just mention that for
foreign
on for more percent of Weiler
a Mr chair my understanding was
represented Weiler was not going to be
here but representative Smith was going
to be making the motion on his behalf or
okay
well done uh Mr chair I moved that late
drafting an introduction of how spills
second
Senator Weber is there any reason not to
amend the motion to include House Bill
25 as well
I don't think so I think that
I I if that you would accept that as a
friendly amendment I would move that we
allow all three and just get them done
as a package
okay
clerk we'll clarify the motion and call
the roll uh thank you Mr chair the
motion is to allow for late Drafting and
introduction of House Bill 1 2 and 25.
representative Packard yes
representative shurtleff yes
representative Smith yes represents
Sanborn yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes motion passes nine to zero Mr
chair the only reason uh they were
scheduled separately is because
representative McConkey is here so that
was he was going to make the
introduction but that's perfectly
acceptable
I'm sure he had a lovely ride down and
okay
this is in no particular order
um
chair uh house amendment to house rule
20 proposed by Representatives Smith and
Wilhelm
let me put a motion do you know
yes
I moved
I moved Mr chairman that we passed this
amendment
sarasacco
protected 20 seconds
thank you Mr Speaker
yeah the um so the point of this is
actually to protect each caucus from
themselves
so that depending on attendance on any
given day we don't try to
special order unpack the day with a
bunch of our big ticket items and
hopefully cooperatively bring stability
motion motion is to uh pass amendment to
house rule 20. Berk will call a roll
represent Packard yes representative
shirtleff yes representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes
motion passes nine to zero excuse me the
amendment
uh amendment to house rule 43b proposed
by Representatives Stephen Smith in
Mr chairman
and move approval of the amendment is
there a second
representative Sweeney representative
Cheryl I'm representative Smith
thank you Mr Speaker um there's a lot of
language to accomplish something really
simple
that exit normally the executive
sessions will be put for a specific date
and time on a calendar
if you can do them as a package the
committee will exec these eight bills at
1 pm that's fine and that's normal
um if the chair
and the uh ranking member as designated
by the minority leader agree and they
have a gap in their schedule they can
pick off some that were not done
normally we put language on the calendar
to allow executive sessions throughout
the day
the point of having the concurrence of
the chair and the ranking member I
thought it was practice I always did it
but this way we established it as policy
that you don't pull a fast one on either
side
and hopefully they can pick off their
work out of the calendar
thank you
discussion
yeah thanks Mr Speaker uh I think this
is just another one of these uh rules
amendment that helps to provide
stability for the chamber uh the last
one was in the on the floor this one's
in committee rooms and uh
happy to co-sponsor and and to vote in
favor
foreign
represent Packard yes representative
shurtleff yes representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yeah representative
amendment to house rule 44 proposed by
represents and Stephen Smith and
happy
I'll move that one
Senator Weber moves is that seconded
representative Sweeney
so let's move the second in uh
representative Smith
thank you Mr Speaker this rule simply
addresses a calendar glitch allowing us
to put things on a calendar to be
noticed for the following Monday to go
from the four to three days notice for
the public hearing otherwise if you're a
committee that meets on Mondays you have
to do everything a week and a half two
weeks in advance thank you
example homes uh thanks Mr Speaker
uh I I think as we've moved to double
rooms and scheduling five days a week
this is really important just so uh
committee chairs can be planful around
if there be no further discussion
clerical call or all represent Packard
yes representative shurtleff yes
representative Smith yes represents
Sanborn yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes represent
Weber yes representative evil yes
motion passes Amendment passes nine to
zero
chair recognizes representative yocella
thank you Mr Speaker and members of the
committee this amendment uh our proposed
World change is just to uh require uh
that the
that the question be placed to the
members twice if the um if a roll call
is sufficiently seconded before ruling
that it isn't just to give people that
have a hard time getting up uh enough
time to stand up
uh Mr chairman I move not to accept the
amendment uh I think is somewhat with
all due respect to the member it's a
solution looking for a problem and I
just don't think it's necessary
thank you Mr Speaker
is there a second I'll second
then Osborne seconds it is there a
discussion
um
uh if if I can provide a theatrical
enactment
um a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded is that
sufficiently seconded
I don't know that this would solve that
problem
the motion before us is not to accept
the amendment to house rule 22. there'll
be no further discussion the clerk will
representative Packard yes
representative shurtleff yes
representative Smith yes representative
Sanborn yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber
represent people yes motion to not
representative Sweeney proposes an
oh representative Smith
you have your hand up
I have to speak yeah
we need a motion first
yes Mr Speaker I moved to adopt the
amendment
first of all I
I'm sure it was right you need to
thank you Mr Speaker and fellow members
of the rules committee today
um as previous rules that we've adopted
already uh amendments we've adopted
already today uh the basis for this is
really a house floor stability rule uh
this is to make sure that when in the
scenario a committee is divided evenly
between them which uh I would expect
we'll see more of this upcoming session
uh that the first motion that the house
will consider will be coming from the
chair or the vice chair if the chair is
absent on the floor of the house and
that's that's my motion
foreign
Mr clerk is it in basins that our our
practice and procedures though when the
Committees are tie that this positive
motion should come to the floor
uh thank you for the question uh the the
situation is that this the two
statements uh regarding what the the two
positions out of the committee were
would be printed in the house calendar
excuse me however our practice and
precedent is that the positive motion is
considered first on the house floor
thank you Mr chair um briefly I'm I'm
going to vote against this motion
um many of us in this chamber including
you Mr Speaker have a great deal of
respect for our practices and precedence
in the traditions of this institution uh
we have always brought in my 19 years
now in the house uh just positive motion
to the floor when the committee is tied
in a vote is the first item taken up is
something that we have always done we
take pride in that I think we should
continue with that practice and
precedent in honor of this house and the
people who have served before us and
have carried on that tradition so I will
be voting no no in the motion thank you
John Weber
I too very much disagree with this
motion and will be voting against it and
that's because these are committee
reports
and they are the report of the whole
committee not the report of the chair of
the committee
and I believe that when a committee is
divided there's good reason for it
because the good arguments on both sides
and as the clerk has told us we put both
of those reports in the calendar
and
if we allow the chair of the committee
to decide which motion gets made first
we negate the work of everybody else on
that committee
and I think it's a very unwise motion
for us to take if we continue always
taking the positive motion first
then they are divided randomly between
those that want the bill to pass and
those that don't want the bill to pass
that's an even division it's an equal
opportunity for each build a stand or
fail on its own merits and I think it
would be a very sad day for this house
if we voted to allow the committee chair
to take over the work of the entire
thank you Mr Speaker I just want to
address the past practice and precedent
issue amazingly I think I've served
under seven speakers and I specifically
recall three of them on the house floor
setting new precedent unilaterally one
of them actually explicitly stated so
our sources of authority practice
practice and precedent are below house
rules so if we're going to do something
different it's changing the house rule
is the proper way to do it so I don't
have any objection based on that
argument
foreign
I don't think we've we've ever had a
situation where we have had more than
one or two no recommendations out of
committees in an entire year we're
looking forward to two years of having
probably you know 150 per year and every
single one of those
um has the
uh
likelihood of having to go through
multiple roll calls
um and it's going to take up a lot of
time every single session day so I don't
know that this proposal is necessarily
the the greatest solution to that but I
think we should probably come up with
some solution
um maybe it's uh that the prevailing
motion is itl rather than OTP or uh or
there are some other mechanism of of
selecting the motion that is most likely
to Prevail on that day at that time and
uh I'd be open to
um to any other suggestions but I think
I think that's my concern
is that we've never been in this
position before
uh and
is this the answer I'm not sure but I
agree with the majority leader
that something
we need to we need to come up with
something that's fair to both sides if
we're going to have a number of no
recommendations
and
just always going forward with the auto
pass motion I I think I think it's
unfair for
either either one of the bodies
Senator Charlie uh Mr chairman I can see
where
you genuinely feel a dilemma over this
situation and I think it's something
that the house should discuss with a
motion to table this amendment be in
order
uh no representative but we can't table
in committee you can not recommend it or
recommend it and it could certainly come
as a floor Amendment as any amendment
can on January 4th since the bill cannot
the amendment cannot be tabled and there
are questions I would ask the committee
to vote against it and let some of us
talk as many as possible and look at the
different scenarios but devote for
something because we don't know what the
future is going to be hold for this body
I just don't think is inappropriate
especially by after the comments by the
majority leader and the speaker having
concerns I think we should not act in
haste and pass something and I'd ask the
committee to vote no on the amendment
the just to clarify if representative
Sweeney wished to withdraw his Amendment
foreign
thank you
I I do believe I do believe though that
um we we do have to come up with a
solution that's fair to both to both
bodies
um
Mr Speaker
I I was just going to comment Before the
bill was withdrawn that I think
traditionally we always have a couple of
relatively light days on our first
couple of session days and I think that
will allow us to see whether the time
issues really are there
or are not there but I I hope that
whatever solution has come up with
uh it may be a a problem in a solution
in search of a problem but if if it
becomes a problem I I think we need to
uh come up with a solution that honors
the work of the entire committee and
does not simply delegate to the chair
that which was
handed to an entire committee for a
resolution thank you yeah I think I I
think yeah having put this one aside
representative Weber uh
I don't know what the solution is
offhand but I think it's it's fair it's
only fair for both bodies that we come
up with some solution
that uh doesn't penalize either one of
our bodies uh would always happen to be
second you know on the motion
so
I guess representative Wilhelm you and I
got some work ahead of us
um
is representative Stephen Pearson here I
don't see him oh there he is they were
hiding uh he is proposing an amendment
thank you Mr Speaker and friends and
colleagues my proposal is to change the
threshold to remove a bill from consent
from one member to three members
three members does not even represent
one percent of our body
the purpose of my Amendment
is to do two things one my understanding
of the purpose of removing a bill from
consent is because there was either new
information brought to light or
circumstances has have changed in a fair
and reasonable argument could be made on
the floor of the houses is to the
content of that change in in fact
overturn the opinion of the committee
that put it on consent
in my two terms in the house I have seen
this you weaponized it has been used
when members were upset that their bills
were put on killed on consent it has
been used to grandstand for speech
purposes and in a divided house that is
nearly tied
I don't think that we have the time for
that now
the threshold of three is not a
Monumental mountain to climb at all if
something is is legitimately uh
legitimately needed to be removed
to find two other members to agree with
your position should not be that
difficult
so that is the purpose of my Amendment
and
um
I'm asking for your support thank you
motion of Charlotte
thank you Mr chair I'd move to accept
the amendment and just to speak briefly
to my emotion I think the uh Majority
Leader spoke eloquently earlier when he
alluded to the fact the time is going to
be of the essence in the upcoming
session
and as the sponsor has said and I know
you've seen him Mr Speaker as have I
there have been times in the history of
the house where members have taken
builds off consent for the simple reason
to be punitive to the whole body and I
think to ask for two additional members
to agree to take a bill of consent is
not that big a hurdle when I think it
this amendment has Merit and I'd ask
your support thank you Mr chair we have
second
of Osborne
um so I gotta tell you I like this idea
in fact I wish it were a larger number
maybe like 50 or so
um but you know that's my personal
opinion I do think there should be a
much higher bar to bring business to the
floor of the house and take up 400
people's time
um
I I worry that uh
you know it's called the consent
calendar for a reason that uh you know
people you know we are consenting to it
and requiring uh an extra two people I
don't know that that's
uh necessarily right to do but I I do
I do like the idea
John Wilbur
I too was on the fence when I when I
read this because I'm thinking about you
know the concept of unanimous consent
and one person withdrawing their consent
and but as has been pointed out we have
the right to change our rules and to
adopt a specific rule for a specific
situation
and I think that this rule is probably a
good idea for specific situation so I'm
going to vote for it but I will say that
there there have been times when
committees have just gotten things flat
out wrong and I'm remembering uh the
requirement that everybody who swam in
Lake Winnipesaukee would be required to
wear a red bathing cap
which came unanimously out of committee
and
which became the subject of a fairly
lengthy debate but
um you know and they were rightly
concerned about safety but
you know people get to make their own
decisions on that kind of thing anyway
um
the more I think about it the more I
think that three people at a minimum
defeats the one person who is trying to
make a point and hold a stall hostage
which has happened in the past so I'm
going to vote for it
I think that
is my concern too is that uh
um we could be held
hostage very easily too many times and
if a member can't come up with two more
members that wants to remove a bill from
consent for good reasons then it
clerk will call a roll
the motion is to accept the amendment
represent Packard yes representative
shirtleff yes representative Smith no
representative Sanborn no
uh no
representative Sweeney no
represent Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes
the motion excuse me the amendment is
chair recognizes representative Betsy to
it's been a while since I've been using
this okay
um I'm proposing a rule change
um to 58 A1
to change
um change it from prayer to invocation
and the reason I'm doing that or
requesting that is that the word
invocation is more inclusive than the
word prayer it also does include the
word prayer if so chooses but it does
mandate that it be a prayer so I uh
right now we have a situation in the
state of New Hampshire where only 20
percent of our citizens attend church on
a regular basis
there are a number in the younger
generation that are not religiously
Affiliated and I just think moving
forward it's would be in our best
interest and show progressiveness to
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um
this proposed amendment would have
nothing to do with eliminating the
position of house chaplain
somebody want to make a motion
Mr Speaker I have a I have a question
first
uh representative thanks for bringing
this forward can you give some examples
of uh aside from prayer what what might
well to me an invocation because it
opens up our session
um
is something that should really speak to
us as a unifying force as a um you know
a call for us to do our duty of that day
to be a celebration of why we're there
um you know to um
uh promote policies for everybody in New
Hampshire and I just think that
um
the individuals that are chosen to come
up and do an invocation would be given
greater latitude in terms of what they
want to say okay and you know some you
know some choose to go down a religious
line and that's fine but others may
choose really to do more of a spiritual
um and
um
I'll say nature-based uh uplifting
speech
um that you know does not have any
religious connotation so I just think
that the word invocation gives that
Latitude to whomever the speaker chooses
to give the um opening
invocation for that day it's still
certainly within the speakers
um purview to do whatever he wants but I
just think it gives everybody it gives
greater latitude to those who are chosen
thank you
Sweeney Mr Speaker I move to reject this
amendment
further discussion
is it Weber
I just want to put on record that I I
too am concerned I well you know the
clerk will tell you that every year we
have our discussion about what is
referred to as the Quaker oath and it's
an imprecise term unless it's in the
Constitution I think or if not in the
Constitution and statute so we're stuck
with it unless we start amending
everything but there are a number of
places in our
laws that we have
in my opinion crossed the line in
assuming uh a particular religious
tradition over all the other religious
Traditions or those members who choose
not to follow a legit religious
tradition and I think that any time that
we can allow our language to be more
inclusive and more acceptable of
everybody's viewpoints
that it is a good thing so I'm going to
thank you Mr Speaker uh as somebody who
grew up in the church who got married in
the church who got confirmed in the
church who got baptized in the church
whose kids got baptized in the church
who uh admittedly doesn't attend church
quite as often as I used to however I'll
be there on Saturday evening
um
I think this is a really uh smart move
for the chamber I think this is you know
this is not a slight of uh people of
faith I certainly don't take it as that
but it's really an effort to be more
inclusive as the representative shared
so I'll be voting in support of it and
hope other members of the committee will
clerical color roll
but the motion is to not accept the
amendment represent Packard yes
Representative sheratliff no
representative Smith yes representative
Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm no representative
Weber no representative evil no
chair recognizes representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr Speaker
um this is uh I'm here to represent
um representative Andrew prout's
Amendment here it's in my name he had a
job I'm unemployed so that's why you get
to talk to me today so
um this is a rule change that imagines
uh maybe
the worst case scenario of what a
divided house may lead us to and that is
when it comes to unanimous consent at
the end of the day potentially a very
long day
that people rise to the floor
a speech a floor speech that's intended
to be contentions and to throw a few
elbows
what this rule would do would be allow
would to allow somebody to to challenge
the con unanimous consent and it would
require a two-thirds vote in order for
the individual to be allowed to continue
that would create a mutually assured
destruction scenario where
the speech the floor speech would need
to be able to Garner some bipartisan
support a significant amount of
bipartisan support to continue and I
think with the proper leadership from
each of the caucus leaders that the
discipline that this would provide would
mean that we would still get interesting
important relevant
unanimous consent speeches before us
but it may
it is intended to prevent those who
might use their opportunity to throw a
few elbows and and given our our numbers
uh given
um that the alternative for the house is
to have individuals who object to the
ask consent just simply leave for the
day early then we start to get into
potential Quorum issues and just
maintenance of the of the house so
um so I would hope that that you would
consider this favorably it's not a new
issue I think we've discussed this
potential rule change or something
similar in the past so hopefully you're
familiar enough with it that you can
apply your own theory on the benefit of
of this proposal
foreign
my question is I'm curious why the bar
was set so high
at a two-thirds vote
that's 66 and two-thirds percent that a
member would need to get the vote of to
be allowed to continue with the consent
of the house and I just can't understand
um I I I respect the question I think
that's a very fair question I I uh in
order to provide you a point of view on
it not one that I necessarily am
passionate about but but the word
unanimous is implies an extremely high
bar and and two-thirds is actually
pretty far away from being unanimous and
so I I think if you look flip it around
and look at it the other way what is a
unanimous consent uh that two-thirds
would reflect a position where it's it's
still a whole lot of people so
um if if uh if you all wanted to change
it to say sixty percent or some other
number I I wouldn't object to it the the
point is
um with our majorities and uh so close
to one another a mere 50 percent on any
given day open a potential can of worms
and so I'm just trying to assure that
that there's some bipartisanship in
there
brother discussion mine was discussion
rather than a question
is that okay why don't we get the motion
for US Representative
well I was trying to figure out what
motion I wanted to make but that's okay
does somebody want to make a motion well
I'd make a push okay
thank you Mr chairman with all due
respect to the member I'd move that we
not accepted I think that number of
requiring a two-thirds vote is extremely
high and
um I think if it was all it brought
before the Lesser number maybe but at
two-thirds it's an awful High uh barrier
for a member to try to uh uh get
permission to continue to speak so I'd
ask the committee to vote no one without
without due respect to my friend from
Robert
second
Weber and I was going to say I I very
much respect the point of view of those
submitting this because I think it is a
a consideration and I'm I'm actually not
opposed to this but I think that there
are a couple of other
issues with unanimous consent that need
to be addressed at the same time and the
other one is the area which we have
where
unanimous consent one member withdraws
their consent there is a vote of the
house to allow the member to proceed
very early on in the discussion the
member precedes the content becomes
exceedingly offensive and there is no
longer any way to stop them because
the the the ruling was at that time that
you could only make the motion once I I
personally would argue
that
further intervening
offensive speech
would allow a renewal of the motion but
I don't think that's articulated well
anywhere and I was unable to come up
with an articulation to present to us
today but I I would like
us to continue to have the discussion
because I do think I do think the point
here is a is well taken but I think it
there's certain there are several things
clerical color roll the motion is to not
accept
yes
representative shirtleff yes
representative Smith yes representative
Sanborn yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes
motion to not accept is adopted nine to
zero
Sweeney
it's proposing an amendment to House
thank you again Mr speaker thank you
again to the members of the committee
um this rules Amendment uh removes the
word bulbs and adds the word a in front
of flash in the current house rules
Banning cameras on the house floor I'm a
big fan of photography I uh well
occasionally around New Hampshire go to
antique shops and buy old cameras that I
can and they all have the old flash bulb
ports where you put a light bulb in uh
but I have not seen one on the house
floor and I've been in and out of the
legislature for the last 10 years
um so I do think the uh the update you
know not to undermine the
institutionalism or the history of the
house and how we do things but I think
this is an area where we can update the
rules or a simple flash does not have a
bulb associated with it anymore and
that's the uh that's it that's the
okay we got a motion to accept is there
any discussion
there's no discussion clerk will call
the motion is to accept representative
Packard yes representative shirtless
yeah representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber
representative evil it's a tough call
but yeah
I'm kidding motion
amendment is accepted nine to zero
uh Mr chairman we have one remaining
that we haven't taken up yet amendment
to house rule 66 which is kind of an
important one house deadlines
oh wow
sorry
yes I have I was just looking for
that okay I knew we hadn't taken that
one up yet so I'll move acceptance Mr
Speaker if that's helpful that that
helps
so we have a motion and a second to
accept the uh house deadlines uh is
representative Weber
I will just note that the
um
deadline to report how spills going to
Second committee has slid
later from where it has been some years
and then
later in the calendar there's some
squashing to make up with that but we're
going to be pressed for time somewhere
in the calendar no matter where we put
things so I see no reason not to adopt
these and I would move that we accept
them
well it gives us a little bit more time
to put the budget together yep
we were always pressed with that and uh
I'm glad that we're moving forward and
giving us a little bit of extra time
well there's no further discussion Clerk
of Colorado
represent Packard yes representative
shirtless yeah representative Smith yes
representative Sanborn yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
evil yes
is there any other business to come
before the rules committee today
Mr chair just a a quick reminder
especially for those who may have
presented uh amendments in the in the
audience
um that we will
um if members do wish to submit floor
amendments uh that that is acceptable
um the same procedure still applies that
we'll need those by the third Tuesday
the third so that we can run copies for
seat Pockets
um to go into uh the the seat pockets
and is that 12 a 12 p.m or 4 P.M on the
3rd I mean we've always said close of
business is that not correct
thank you
um ish I would just be mindful that
needing to run 400 copies takes more
than 10 minutes though so if if if you
do have something the earlier in the day
so that I can get them prepared in NC
Pockets that is helpful with the staff
there'll be no further business we're
having a motion to adjourn